oh
it's not cheap
hey what's up hot shot
party
tell me about that tip what
I want to know about that tip oh baby
time what's so on right now all right I
just need to know where it came from
it's got to be airtight
okay
I was at a wine tasting with my cousin
Ernesto which was mainly Reds and you
know I don't like reds man you know but
there was a rose that saved the day it
was delightful and he tells me about
this girl Emily that we used to kick it
with it was actually the first pair of
boobs that ever touched it's the wrong
details it's a wrong it has nothing to
do with the story go
so uh he tells me that she's working as
a housekeeper now right and she's dating
this dude Carlos who is a shot caller
from across the bay and she tells him
about the dude that she's cleaning for
right that he's like this big shot CEO
that is all retired now but it's loaded
and so Carlos and Ernesto are in the
same softball team and they get to
talking right and here comes the good
part Carlos says yo man this guy's got a
big ass save just sitting in the
basement just chilling of course Ernesto
comes to me because he knows I got mad
Demons of course I asked him did Emily
tell Carlos to tell you to get to me
what kind of safe it was and he says Nah
dog all she said is that it's like super
legit and whatever's in it it's Gotta Be
Good
[Music]
what
old man have safe
Anna's gone for a week all right there's
an old man he's got a safe and he's gone
for a week let's just work with that you
know what I'm saying